hi everyone welcome to our fourth
tutorial in our imaging science series
my name is Brian runoff I'm the
education coordinator at the MIT Museum
and today we're going to be looking at
Astro photography Astro photography is a
great way to familiarize yourself with
the motion of the earth and the Stars
and the planets and satellites in the
space station there's so much stuff out
there and Astro photography gives you
the time to take some time look up at
the stars and discover something new
Astro photography presents its own set
of unique challenges things such as
light pollution from nearby nearby
buildings or even light from the moon on
them you don't realize how bright the
moon is until you start trying to take
images especially when the moon is full
you're also competing with the weather
so Oh know if there's clouds on the
night that you want to go out you're not
going to be able to take star pictures
so the weather is going to get away as
well as the fact that there's really
just not much light the sky is dark at
night so we're going to look at several
techniques that we can use to help get
around these challenges and take some
really cool Astro photography shots it
was also important to note that because
our subject in this case the sky at
night is very dark it's going to be
difficult to get enough light cellphones
because their lenses are very small have
difficulty gathering this light so your
images from a cell phone are not going
to be as clear as those from a camera
with a larger lens but that being said
we are going to cover some techniques
and in this tutorial that'll help you
take some pretty good Astro photos even
if you're shooting with the cell phone
in order to get around some of the
challenges that I previously mentioned
there's some things that you can do in
preparation to do Astro photography to
help you the first one is there are many
applications out there for your phone or
computer that are guides to the sky
they'll tell you when certain things
rise and set on the horizon where
they're going to be and these will be
very helpful in planning what you would
like to take pictures of the next one
also a phone application or on your
computer it's check the weather
especially our by our forecasts you can
see that actually this is the forecast
from today when I'm recording the video
it's actually going to be very clear
tonight which is great for
astrophotography you want to avoid
obviously clouds and rain so plan ahead
the next thing that I recommend is a
flashlight now not just any flashlights
if possible use a red flashlight red
flashlights do not ruin your night
vision as much it takes a long time for
your eyes to adjust and you'll notice
the longer you spend outside the more
stars you're just going to be able to
see with the naked eye so by using a red
flashlight you'll still be able to light
things in order to adjust camera
settings or whatever you need to do but
also not ruin that night vision that you
work so hard to get
lastly astrophotography does take
patience we're going to be taking some
long exposure photos we're going to be
taking lots of images we'll be waiting
for clouds to pass we'll be waiting for
things to come up above the horizon and
out of the way of trees so even during
the summer it gets kind of cold at night
dress warmly so bring some warm clothes
sweatshirt gloves whatever you need
because it will get chilly out there
now that you have what you need to to
start shooting let's start talking about
our camera settings for our exposure
triangle um the first thing we're going
to talk about is aperture now with
astrophotography because everything
we're photographing is so far away what
we say it's all at infinity we don't
have to worry about depth of field so we
can shoot with a very wide aperture or
your lowest aperture settings F 1.4 2.8
3.5 whatever the lowest you can set if
you're using an interchangeable lens
camera by having a wide aperture that
will also help you capture more
let more photons enter your camera to
give you a brighter image now with that
though because your depth of field is
low and you're focusing on something far
away focus is very important so whether
you're using a cell phone and a point
shoot interchangeable lens camera it's
really easy to get out of focus stars
and I've had lots of nights when I've
gone out to shoot and I come back to
look at my images and all my hard work I
end up with these types of blurry images
and it's because I was slightly out of
focus so what I recommend in order to
make sure you have these pinpoint stars
is to use manual focus and take lots of
test shots so turn off the auto focus on
your camera you're going to use the
manual focus setting focus it look in
the camera try to get them sharp take a
picture then zoom in and check to see if
your star turn focus if they're not
adjust and try again and do that a few
times to make sure that when you start
spending a lot of time taking your
photos you get really sharp stars
now the next settings we're going to
talk about is the shutter speed now in
order to capture the most light as
possible and get a bright image you're
going to want to use a fairly long
shutter speed when you use long shutter
speeds because you're capturing more and
more light you're going to start being
able to see all these dim stars that you
may not be able to see with the naked
eye so you may discover something new
stars just by using this long shutter
speed now when you do this I recommend
that you use a shutter speed that is no
longer than 30 seconds to keep your
stars as pinpoints so keep your image
really sharp now the reason why I say 30
seconds is that the earth is spinning
and the earth is spinning once around
its axis every 24 hours and what that
causes is motion blur so you can see in
this image this isn't due to camera
shake but this is due to the motion of
the earth as it spins
that these stars are getting stretched
out and you see these trails now these
trails can actually be used for a really
cool effect you may have seen images
with star trails and we'll talk about
how to take images with these star
trails on purpose a little bit later in
this video but if you're trying to get
pinpoint stars and see lots of stars
really clearly be careful about setting
your shutter speed to be too long so the
long shutter speed allows us to take
brighter images even though there's not
much available light in the sky but it
also introduces another problem camera
shake so if your camera moves during
that long exposure during that 30
seconds or 15 seconds or whatever you're
using you're going to get blur so it is
super important to use a tripod now it's
okay if you don't have your own tripod
because I'm going to show you now how to
make your own stable tripod for whether
it's your phone or your camera um
there's a bunch of different ways to do
this the important part here is that the
tripod is stable meaning it's weighted
down or connected to whatever surface
you're using in a way that is going to
prevent it from shaking now firstly
don't forget the simple solution so we
could always just put our cameras face
up at the sky this actually works
surprisingly well I've taken photos like
this and it works as long as whatever
you want to image is straight up it also
prevents you from seeing your screen so
if you want to take multiple shots of
the same thing that will be a little bit
of an issue but it's the quick and
simple solution if you want to point
your camera at a specific point in the
sky there are a couple of different
options so these are some that we came
up with here and so this on the left is
a quick clamp that's holding the
cellphone very stable and I added this
wait here in order to keep it keep it
locked down to the surface and that
worked actually really well for long
exposures here's another one that we
built using cardboard and this by taping
the edges here in different places you
can adjust the angle that your phone is
pointing to also aim your camera in a
third example here is using a cardboard
tube where I've cut out slots here for
the phone the phone sits here and then
I've waited it down it happens that this
tube fits right in the tape and the tape
is holding this down to the table to
make a stable tripod for larger
interchangeable-lens cameras you can
actually use this similar system so in
this case I'm actually using the exact
same cardboard stand that used for the
cell phone but just prop the camera up
on the other side and here's the picture
in the middle here is the the back view
of that and we're using this tape here
to provide a little extra stability to
the camera this lets me access all the
controls to the camera while keeping the
camera in the same place in the last
example here it's similar using
cardboard but this design allows us to
weight down our stand a little bit too
and we're using some coins here to keep
our camera pointed in the direction that
we want again super important when
you're using these long exposure times
make sure that you have a stable tripod
or your pictures your going to be blurry
the last setting that we're going to
look at is ISO now for your ISO higher
values are going to allow you to capture
more detail especially if we're looking
at things like the Milky Way but it also
adds more noise so you're going to want
to pick an ISO based on your particular
camera and how much noise your camera is
going to produce this will also be
affected as how by how much light
pollution is around because a higher ISO
not only makes your camera
more easily detect like from the stars
but also light from around you so you
can see in this picture here I use the
high ISO which allowed the stars up at
the top of the image to be nice and
bright but at the same time it captured
all this glow from the city down here in
my milky way shot you can see again lots
of color you can see detail in the Milky
Way you can even see some shooting stars
but it's a little bit grainy err so
there's some greenish purple in there
that's actually a result of using high
ISO in some cases and it's personal
preference how much noise you would like
in your image so definitely experiment
and see what it looks like now here's an
example with really high noise so in
this image I've boosted the ISO really
really high so you can see and you can
see all the graininess here and the
different colors in the image and that's
caused by having ISO that's too high so
again can't really give you a specific
number but you're going to have to
experiment with your camera to balance
the amount of noise and the amount of
detail and brightness of the image but
in general try to rely on your shutter
speed and aperture to get the exposure
before adjusting your ISO too high so
now that we've talked about how to take
nice sharp images with lots of stars
let's see how to take advantage of the
spin of the earth to create some effects
that will create some really stunning
images so what we're gonna look at are
what are called star trails and so in a
star trail image you're actually
tracking the movement of the stars over
time so as the earth is spinning it's
going to look like the stars are
rotating around in the sky and they're
actually going to be rotating around or
seemingly rotating around the North Pole
or the North Star so in my image you can
actually find where North is by the
center of all the Rings so if I
follow these circles here the North Star
is right behind the trees here where all
of these stars are circling around so
this photo was created by stacking many
images of the sky over the course of two
hours on top of each other so this isn't
a single photo and to take this the
shutter speed for each of those photos
it was probably about a hundred photos
here was 30 seconds and you could
actually even go a bit longer and by
using a long shutter speed it allows the
stars and the images to move a little
bit and you get a little bit of motion
blur in each image and many cameras have
what are called intervalometer z' built
in these let you choose the starter
speed of your camera and how often you
want your camera to take a photo so you
don't have to stand outside for the full
two hours so you can set up the
intervalometer point your camera focus
it start it go inside and draw some hot
chocolate and then go out and check your
camera every once in a while just to
make sure that your battery isn't dying
and once you have all of those images
let me show you what they look like
so you can see as I take the images over
these two hours the stars are circling
around that North Star so we can now
insert these into there's a lot of free
software out there in this case I'm
using one called star Stax and when I
put this in the software and click stack
you can see that it's going to blend
these images together in order to create
consistent trails across the sky this is
why you want a little bit of blur in
your photo a little bit of that motion
blur to help connect those images
together you can see in a couple of
points in the image you can see some
dots and that's because my shutter speed
was probably just not quite long enough
in order to fill in those gaps in the
photo now let's take a step away from
stars for a second and talk about
photographing the moon a lot of you have
probably had this frustrating experience
so if you see the moon up in the sky it
looks big and bright and and you see all
the details and then you go to take a
picture of it and it looks like this
it's a tiny bright dot so let's talk
about why this happens and then talk
about a few ways to avoid this to make
the moon look like it looks like to your
own eyes the reason why this is a
problem is that the moon is relatively
small compared to the things around you
on the ground in the sky and it's also
very bright so your camera especially in
a cell phone is going to have difficulty
exposing for both the dark part of your
images and the bright part of your
images so the moon gets what we call the
blown out it's so bright that we just
can't capture any detail it's also
really small so it's hard to pick out
those details so how do we solve these
problems well the first thing is it's
really small so what I recommend is
taking your photo if you have one
through binoculars or a telescope or if
you have if you have an interchangeable
lens camera use something with a long
length the more that you can zoom into
the moon or into your photo the more
detail you're going to be able to see
this picture in the middle here for
example this was taken through the
telescope with the cellphone and you can
see a lot of detail here in the moon so
this helps us get at the the moon is
very small problem but how do we solve
the brightness problem so even if I can
zoom in here's a picture of the moon and
it's still very bright so how do I get
my image to be darker and you can see in
the image on the right here there's a
lot more detail I can see the kind of
striations near the South Pole of the
moon here and the different types of
rock a lot more is becoming clear so to
do this use a shorter shutter speed so a
shorter shutter speed is going to get
rid of a lot of that excess light and we
can also decrease our ISO and this is
why again it's super important as we
talked about in previous tutorials to
have access to manual settings on
whatever camera you're using by raising
that shutter speed and dropping the ISO
you're going to be able to capture
images of the moon that are much more
detailed than you are able to get before
another tip for photographing the moon
that's actually even easier than
adjusting your settings you can even do
this on auto mode is photograph the moon
during the day during the day you don't
have that huge range of light the
darkness of the sky versus the really
bright moon everything is at a more
level brightness so your cameras going
to be able to expose oh the image a lot
more easily so if you haven't tried it
try taking your image during the day and
you're gonna see a lot more detail than
you do at night if you don't have a
telephoto lens or binoculars around to
wrap up the last thing I would like to
talk about is how to how to add
something a little bit extra to your
photos to make them really interesting
and this is going to be foreground
and it's great to take images of what we
called star fields they're really
interesting you can see all the number
of stars you can look at specific stars
constellations but you can make these
photos a little bit more interesting by
adding some context to them by including
some foreground so let people know where
you are where was this image taken what
do the stars look like relative to where
you are and this can be a little bit
tricky because the sky is really dark
there's not much light on the things
around you but if you expose your camera
and make your settings so that things
close to you are really bright then
you're not going to be able to see the
stars or if you expose for the stars and
the things in the foreground are going
to be way too bright so how do you how
do you control that and then a lot of
times the images that you see that have
foreground in them are actually what are
called composite so what you would do is
take an image of the stars and expose
your set your settings expose for the
sky and then you do a separate photo
that has the correct exposure for what's
in front of you and then you combine
them but there are a few ways to
actually do this without using any
software so what you can see here is I
actually did what is called light
painting and I set my camera up so I'm
exposing for the stars so I use a long
shutter speed in order to capture the
detail in the sky that I want and then
what I do is during that exposure I take
a flashlight that's are in the first
picture I use a flashlight in a second
when I'm using just the light from my
cell phone
and the third one I'm actually using
moonlight the moon was really bright
that night so I couldn't actually see
the Milky Way but it ended up lighting
this castle in a really neat way but
using the ambient light to light the
things around you so if you're using a
flashlight or cell phone what you can do
is just briefly so let's say you're
doing a 30 second exposure turn on that
flashlight shine it
the objects in your foreground that you
want to be able to see in your photo and
then turn it off just like we talked
about in the high speed video your
camera is only going to record light
when light is present so by only turning
your light on and shining it around on
the objects that you want in your
picture and then turning it off you're
going to get the brightness that you
want on the foreground without it being
overexposed you're only going to capture
light when your light sources on and you
can experiment with how long you leave
the light on to get the best results
thank you for joining us for this
tutorial in our imaging science series
with the MIT Museum and Koch Institute
we'd love to see your stunning science
photos if you'd like to share them with
us you can show them on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram and use the hashtag MIT em
imaging science to share those with us
at the end of this program so on June
20th will be holding a webinar to look
at what makes a great science photo and
some of the so submissions have a chance
to be featured during that webinar for
more information on the imaging science
program other tutorials and other
information and resources please visit
the MIT Museum website at the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the Imaging Science
program